e aí é que as cantadas poucos games alan
patrick também escuto de fortaleza tá
chovendo um frio bem ok
são 12 40 da manhã e vou gravar feito
pra você porque eu gravo no ano passado
cantou uma música tocando teclado que eu
acho muito bonito né eu cantei essa
música e um monte de gente começou a me
perguntar se eu era o evangelho com isto
é evangélico é crente o instituto é o
que meu deus
com isso acredite eu me sentia e eu fui
lá no facebook e twitter galera que
seria interessante para um vídeo sobre
religião não no meu deus do faz não eu
nunca te dislike do vídeo ter o meu deus
não é melhor não fazer nós não vai
manchar sua imagem não não não não não
eu falo assim a fifa fala mal é melhor
nem faltem meu deus do céu que eu vou
perder a minha sala e vai falando mal de
alguém ou de alguma coisa eu falei meu
irmão vou fazer eu resolvi contato desde
o início tudo pra você quando estava na
5ª 6ª série e eu falei eu como eu falei
pra vocês eu não estudei pré-escolar
jardins no jardim do jardim telco meu
pai me botou a primeira série para quem
fosse do dvd com força mesmo na primeira
série é conhecer um dia chamado jorge
virou amigo e tal e por amizade fora ele
inteiro para casa dele tinha um monte de
brinquedo ele tinha um trator e um
ônibus bem grandão onde era bem grande e
tipos e do tamanho da topete bem grande
mesmo assim o tamanho de uma casa do
tamanho de uma criança tipo do tamanho
da minha rua e eu sempre que seu melhor
eu sempre que seu médico olha que eu
queria permitir o ato pequeno e um
ônibus grande é que eu queria brincar
o ônibus era maior de todos e depois de
um tempo ele começou a falar de deus pra
mim o leão e máscaras daquelas que a
gente vai fazer negócio de grande e
pequeno estando lá tudo a pegar fogo
está nas igrejas neste caso devido à
luta dos vídeos o bicho e ficar bem que
nesse caso de doido e ele começou a
falar de deus campeão ligado porque uma
criança criança não quer saber de deus
mas do jeito que ele falava de deus pra
mim era muito má porque criança criança
não é hipócrita a criança não é falsa a
criança olha o goleiro fala baleia a
criança não é planejada no filho com
vergonha da legenda ela chega o
planejado era famoso por que você é
assim que consegue diferente de mim ela
é verdadeira atenção que ela chamou de
balela não quero ofender o corpo da
criança chamou o gordo de baleia por quê
pra ela e lhe parece uma baleia não vai
guardar isso pra ela fala como baleia
então jeito que ele fala de deus pra mim
era muito má é como se fosse uma coisa
que todos os pastores falar-se-á
adiantou que de uma forma filtrada por
um criança e aí eu fui pra igreja com
ele foi quando eu comecei a evangélica e
foi na igreja com aprendi a tocar eu
aprendi a cantar eu crescer e eu comecei
a gostar de outras coisas e aí eu saí
daí vai ter um monte de gente vai falar
agora tá vendo ninguém duro nessa merda
igreja só tem ladrão igreja só tem
corruptos gente no tirol zona e fala que
faz milagre meu deus só desse jeito não
sai da igreja porque não concordava com
que o pastor falava eu não saí da igreja
porque eu deixei de acreditar em deus
não sai da igreja porque eu acho que o
mundo a emenda e que não tem mais
solução eu saí porque eu quis
outras pessoas estão falando é aí ele
abriu os olhos para a verdade agora não
acredita mais em usar eu acredito em
deus assim como eu acredito que esse
tênis e se tem está aqui na minha frente
eu vou dizer pra vocês porque eu
acredite eu sou contra eu confesso que
às vezes um pouco de medo porque até um
pouco traumatizado que quando a gente é
criança em um momento da nossa vida que
a gente descobre a masturbação não isso
é que eu não sei o que a masturbação
ainda bonita
meu deus olha esse menino falando sobre
masturbação para crianças onde já se viu
isso esse menino é um mau exemplo cala
tua boca que faz coisa pior vai cuidar
desse tronco vai surgindo então eu
escolhi uma renovação na igreja a gente
sempre aprender o que deus é onipotente
onisciente e onipresente dentinho
ronaldo geografia zona roupa
o menino morava na roça e foi para o
curral chuva no respeito da va é a bunda
ficava um pouco atordoado porque se deus
é onipresente então quer dizer que
quando tivesse me machucado quando ele
estava a ficar toda hora que toda vez
que tentava uma jogada linda que deus
cavalli olhando pra mim assim é não sair
não era mais ou menos assim direita' tem
jeito a nome do meu nome estava em meu
deus
meu tio hugo e para baixo lençol mas
deus é onipresente ele vai estar
bastante só comigo e eu ficava um pouco
atordoado e eu fui crescendo e eu sou
uma pessoa muito observador observa um
ateu eu observo religioso observa
homossexual observa eficiente observa o
gordo observo madrid e também chegou
aquele meu dia na dúvida a será que deus
exige mas se deus existe porque tem
tanta desgraça no mundo também para eu
também venci o time todo santo é muita
gente não está pensando assim agora ele
vai mentir dizendo que aconteceu um
milagre na vida dele dizendo que
aconteceu uma coisa sobrenatural para
tentar fazer me comover e acredita em
deus não aconteceu nada eu sempre gostei
de cantar hábito em cantos mais espanto
eu sempre gostei de cantar uma das
coisas que sempre me deixou muito feliz
e confortável e cantar pensando em deus
você que não acredita em deus pode ser a
maior barrici de esteira que você já
ouviu na sua vida aqui que eu vou cantar
pensando uma coisa que não existe agora
eu quero que você entenda uma coisa
agora quero que você entenda o apoio pra
mim é muito importante é esse o ponto
que eu queria chegar nesse vídeo uma
coisa que pra mim é muito importante
quando você fala mal dessa coisa isso me
machuca mas tem alguém fazendo hoje que
é alguém fazendo hoje esse cheiro em
confundir faz três anos que eu moro só
eu conheço cheio de miojo a 100
quilômetros de distância em mim eu vou
dar um exemplo pra você e eu tenho esse
tempo eu tenho esse tempo eu gosto muito
desse tempo porque eu não sei mas não
gosto muito desse tempo de alguém fala
pra mim muitas só você gosta de si desde
o início você busca o seu idiota por
gostar desse tempo você ao invés
importantes itens por um negócio é esse
tênis aqui agora agora me fala você
melhor que o que você gosta de se ter
daqui você é mais inteligente deus o
mais burro que você porque eu gosto
desse tempo aqui o fato não é se deus
existe ou não fato é que você tá falando
mal de uma coisa que eu acredito em uma
coisa que eu tenho como importante para
mim mas é bom que tem clientes
quer brigar comigo é porque tem cliente
que quer enfiar coisa na minha cabeça é
porque tem gente que é ignorante beleza
para então trata com a ignorância é essa
pessoa que tá todo mundo não há mais
espaços verdes que roubaram milhões dos
fiéis e fizeram e fizeram os fiéis de
idiota 8 fala pra mim eu já roubei já
vinha do bolso da calça do meu pai
manoel carlos um cara que roubou a
igreja tenha ele fica ou teve um cara
que roubou a igreja não odeia a igreja
não temos pastor que rouba tendo os
padres dada porque que são padrão filia
temos deputado que rouba e meia toda
essa meta tem pessoa bem intencionada o
mundo é uma merda o mundo é um lixo
mundo não serve pra nada no mundo não
têm salvação galera o mundo não é o lixo
o mundo é a lata de lixo lixo a gente a
gente que faz isso aqui vira essa merda
de lixo se tiver bem você pode usar uma
bota até comida no papel higiênico é
papel gente sim aquele mesmo que você
passa no seu currículo papel higiênico
não é nojenta este papel ele não é longe
ele é higiene papel higiênico limpa e
seca tudo o que deixa o papel higiênico
no jeito você está porque o que você
passa ele no seu com a abih meu amigo
jorge lá da primeira série ele ainda
continua sendo meu amigo dias atrás eu
fui no casamento do jorge que foi lindo
lindo demais ele continua evangelho eu
não sou mais o evangelho eu acredito em
deus ea gente continua a mesma amizade
de criança mesmo amizade pura de criança
então eu acredito em deus tem algo que
me conforta e você não entendeu o
problema meu agora não é porque você não
acredita nele que eu sou mais burro que
você nem você mais inteligente que eu
não é porque você é ateu e não é porque
você é ateu que você mais porque eu e
nem porque eu acredito em deus ou ainda
a gente você vai pro inferno capim
ceretta brincando eu sei que tem algumas
pessoas que não acreditam em deus em
assistente você me achar uma pessoa
idiota por causa disso tudo bem faz você
quiser eu fiz aí o que 120 vídeos pra
vocês vocês sabem como eu sou você sabe
a pessoa que eu sou você vai deixar de
me acompanhar por causa das minhas
opiniões coxa uma pena muito obrigado
foi bom você também acompanha até aqui e
sabe que eu gosto muito de você e eu
espero que você fale bem de mim com as
pessoas que você com todo esse você
concordou com o que eu falei deixa
aquele gostei eu quero que você comente
aqui em baixo a sua opinião todos
a opinião é bem vinda se você quiser me
xingar pode pegar se xingamento enfiar
dentro do seu culpa nem fim do ego
patagônia tinha medo de ninguém mas sua
opinião é bem vindo então e que inverter
se cometem foi que o japão entanto a
madrugada na hora valeu e é nós
eu amo vocês todas as pessoas os brancos
negros desde os ateus é a religião
também beijo beijo no coração e no
fígado
será um colega